isabelle morini bosc qui est avec nous
elle est en duplex
isabelle est ce qu elle m'entend bonsoir
mais à cherry hill à célébrer
l'anniversaire gentil gentil tout ça tu
m'entends balles sherri iphone ipod ou
la mer des cordes a tant aimé tu es un
petit truc à isabelle la pauvre mettez
lui un truc
mettez lui un truc la peau mais normes
epa slip
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
isabelle regard des amis plus grave en
plus vous m'entendez j'allais voir un
coup de souris je pensais pas que
c'était savard était là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons alors isabelle arguments
faire un parcours vous allez récupérer
les cadeaux pour le public tout le
public à duras et cadeaux il ya un
premier cadeau cinq ans fait cosmétiques
après il ya des bijoux changeable après
l'énoncé connecter pour l'anniversaire
des magasins but et enfin peut-être que
tout public gagnera une qui grâce à nos
amis de ma petite isabelle s'il vous
plaît on va jouer en kadouch isabelle
faut vous mettre bien et vous redressez
sinon ça va être dangereux pour vous
mettez vous bien dans le siège
sinon ça va être dangereux mais je vous
jure non mais bien là qui menace et nous
savons tous que ça va être dangereux
ces filles isabelle mettez tout plein
air
[Applaudissements]
isabelle attention ces parts et tu as
une minute à base y allez y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
ouais
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
une folie
[Musique]
être accrue
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]